DANA HAN-KLEIN: Hi everyone.
Welcome to Talks at Google.
My name's Dana
Han-Klein, and today it's
my pleasure to introduce Eisner
Award-winning author, Jeffrey
Brown.
He's here with his latest book,
"Darth Vader and Friends."
Welcome.
JEFFREY BROWN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Yeah.
So you're going to tell us a
little bit about your process,
right?
JEFFREY BROWN: Yeah.
Yeah.
Apologies to these people who
are apparently the dark side.
And these must be
the light side.
So a few years ago-- I guess I
won't tell the-- are you going
to ask about--
DANA HAN-KLEIN: I was, but--
JEFFREY BROWN: --the back story?
DANA HAN-KLEIN: --you can
start with the back story.
JEFFREY BROWN: I'll wait
with the back story.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: You can
do the crawl right now.
JEFFREY BROWN: But this was a
book I did three years ago now
called "Darth Vader and
Son" and the concept
is Luke Skywalker
being four years old
and Darth Vader having to
raise him as a single dad.
And I followed that
with a book, which
I realized after I
was on the way here,
I should have included
the other books.
But there's a sequel,
"Vader's Little Princess"
where, of course
Princess Leia needs
to be the rebellious teenager.
And then I found out
that lots of parents
were reading these books
to their kids at nighttime,
and they're
humor-gag books which
didn't seem like a proper
nighttime bedtime book.
So then I did a book called
"Goodnight, Darth Vader"
that was more just
specifically for kids.
And after that I kind of
used up a lot of material.
I try to use all real scenes
and quotes from the films.
But I had this idea of doing
a book about R2 and C-3PO
and how they're friends,
and I had the title LOL
R2-D2, C-3PO BFF.
And then to pitch
it to Lucas Film
I came up with a few ideas.
My editor at Chronicle Books,
Steve Bacchus said, "You know,
are you really going to
be able to sustain C-3PO
and R2-D2 for an entire book?"
And I was like, "Oh, I don't
know if I can, actually."
And part of the problem is that
they're kind of comic relief
in the movies
anyway, so I used up
all the jokes that I could
make that weren't already
jokes in the films.
But he pointed out the
theme of friendship runs
throughout the
"Star Wars" films,
and you have Han Solo and
Chewbacca, and Lando and Lobot,
and the ranker and
the ranker keeper.
You have all these
great friendships.
And so maybe by
expanding the concept out
it could include all
these other characters,
which sounded great.
So I added some more
sketches with some
of the other characters and
we pitched that to Lucas Film.
And there was a pause
while they waited figured
out what they wanted to do
with the new movie coming out
later this year, but in the
end they liked it enough
and they were like, yeah,
let's go ahead and do this.
So one of the first things
to work on was the cover.
And so these are some
of the cover sketches,
and trying to capture the feel
of the book, and the theme,
and hit all the characters.
But in the end, the
sketch that they liked
was actually one of the ideas
I had for an interior page,
and it was just Luke, Leia
and Han climbing on Vader
and using the famous "yippee"
line from Episode one.
And so from there,
the cover process
is usually you do
a bunch of sketches
and then you get feedback
and you narrow it
down to the concept
you like, and then
start working on more and
more finished sketches.
So I did three versions
in color with kind
of various combinations
of characters.
And they liked
this one, but they
liked Lando holding the
stormtrooper helmet,
and they asked about
having R2 and 3PO.
And I was trying
to figure out how
to fit 3PO in the composition
and not have it be too crowded.
So eventually ended
up with this sketch.
And from there came up
with the finished art.
And so there's the cover.
But the hard part for
this book was actually
the interior pages.
And so the books are 64 pages
and there's a copyright page
and a title page.
So there's about 60-- I needed
to come up with about 60 ideas.
So for this book I
came up-- in order
to get to 60 ideas for the book,
I came up with around 140 ideas
that I sketched out.
And so some of them are
based on my own experiences
with friends.
You know, losing your best
friend to someone else,
as Lobot did.
He doesn't even get to show
up and return to the Jedi
because [INAUDIBLE] is
Lando's new best friend.
This is an idea.
I wanted to do something
with the X-wing pilots,
and you can see I'll put
notes to myself about things
that I might switch out later.
And this is all
these friends who
are X-wing pilots had just
worked out their problems
and buried their
hatchets and then
they're going on the I'll get
killed in the Death Star run.
One of the other things that I
had the chance do in this book
was try and fit some
jokes about the prequel.
So here you have
Captain Typho, who
of course is the seeing eye.
And he sees Anakin and
[INAUDIBLE] and the other guy
says, "didn't see
that coming, did you?"
Get it?
This was probably
my favorite one
that didn't end up
making it into the book.
That's and younger
Anakin and Qui-Gon,
or it's Qui-Gon and
young Obi Wan Kenobi
talking about midi-chlorians.
"This midi-chlorian
reading is off the charts.
Not even Yoda has
a count his high.
No Jedi has-- Do you
know what that means?
Huh?
What, what?
Sorry, I kind of zoned out
when you said midi-chlorian."
And then there's young Anakin
throwing a fit because he
can't be in the Jedi Council.
This is another
one that I really
liked that was just maybe a
little too violent or implying
too much violence for the book.
So it's little Luke,
and he's wondering
what this button
does as the ranker is
standing under the gate.
So I wrote these
books for adults,
but when I started I wanted
to make them kid-friendly.
So there's some jokes like this
that just don't make the cut.
This is another joke
that I've actually
pitched for various books.
So the idea of putting
C-3PO back and it's
like when you get together as a
family to put puzzles together.
And then I also pitched
it as Christmas morning
when you get the bicycle
and then you have
to put the bicycle together.
Instead it's C-3PO, and
Vader has to figure out--
he's trying to figure out
how to put C-3PO together.
But the process is
going back and forth
with the editor at Lucas Film,
the editor at Chronicle Books,
and we all kind of
go back and forth
about which ones
we like the most
and which ones we'd
like to include.
And I was the only one who ever
was voting for this concept.
But there it is.
I also, I didn't get
Boba Fett into the book
as much as I wanted, and so this
is one of my Boba Fett jokes
that maybe needed to be
developed a little more.
And it's just all the
guys at Java's Palace
think Boba Fett's so cool,
and they're like "Stay.
Hang out with us."
Boba says, "I guess
it can't hurt."
Because-- this is a
spoiler, but if you
haven't seen "Return of
the Jedi," Boba Fett,
he stays at the palace
and then he dies.
And then here's another one.
This is one that I-- so some
of the jokes and ideas I'll
sketch out I know won't
be used in the books,
but I just do it for
my own amusement.
So of course this is Luke at
Han Solo trying to buy beer.
And you don't need to
see our identification.
And this is another idea
that I really liked,
and it's the battle droids,
and the lead battle droid is
like "You guys are the best."
And then they go out and
they're just getting massacred,
and like, "You guys suck."
And then he's like, "I'm sorry.
I didn't mean that."
Because in the end,
they're all in it together.
So I did the pencils and
the feedback on this one
was there was just
too much going on
or the joke wasn't
getting across.
So I redid another
two-panel version,
and even that one, the response
was that it was too much.
And so then I just
simplified it down.
It's just a little sweeter
and more straightforward.
But it's still funny.
And then sometimes I would
get an idea from other people,
so this is an idea from my
editor at Lucas Films who
was J.W. Rinzler.
I don't know if any of you
have read the big coffee table
making of Star Wars books.
But he wrote those, but
he's also worked with me
on all my Vader books.
And he said, how
about doing something
based on the Annie Hall scene.
So if you've seen the movie
"Annie Hall" with Woody Allen,
and there's a scene
where they're driving
and Annie is just driving
crazy and Woody Allen's
just terrified.
And then he is reaching
down for something
and he finds a sandwich.
So the initial idea was to
have it be Anakin and Obi-Wan
on [INAUDIBLE].
And it just didn't seem to
fit with the rest of the book.
And I realized it
would make more sense
to have it be Obi-Wan riding
in Luke's landspeeder.
So for all the images I
would pencil up the full page
and Lucas Film would
approve all the pencils.
And once the pencils
are approved,
then we'd work on the final art.
One of the things I liked being
able to include in the book
is just the imperial
officers who
are just-- I think they
don't get enough screen
time to be funny.
And I managed to fit in
my original high-fiving R2
and C-3PO, as well as
2-1B is the medical droid,
one of my favorite droids.
If you watched college
football or any sporting event
where there's a band, they
all know the Imperial March.
And I decided it seems like
people play that whenever
they have a chance.
And so I thought
it would make sense
if anywhere Vader
showed up, there'd
just be a band
there playing that.
Yeah.
This was just from
a page where I
tried to fit in every
creature and character
that I hadn't been able
to fit in somewhere else.
And so Luke's line,
"I grew up here.
There's nothing really to see."
Then of course it's just
all these fantastic aliens
and creatures.
And then this is the
final page of the book,
and it's a twist
on a line that's
in every film, which is "I've
got a bad feeling about this."
And then it just kind
of wraps up the book,
"I've got a good
feeling about this."
Maybe a little sappy and
sweet, but I think that's OK.
We'll save that for, or
should I do that now?
DANA HAN-KLEIN: OK.
JEFFREY BROWN: So
I thought I would--
you might think that it's really
difficult to draw Darth Vader,
but it's actually really simple.
So I'm going to
walk you through-- I
just realized I need a big pen.
So this is how to
draw Darth Vader.
So first you draw
the half circle,
which is coincidentally how you
start to draw the Death Star.
Draw a line down the middle.
You might want take your time
and make those more even,
or else people will think Vader
is just questioning everything.
I, however, being an
experienced artist
know that when
you make mistakes,
you can just fix them.
So draw the crescent moon.
And then you can start
drawing triangles.
Draw a bunch of triangles.
More triangles.
It's really all triangles.
Vader needs to breathe, and
so you just add your lines.
So there's Vader.
So Vader's helmet is
just this static thing,
and you can't
really-- in the movies
it's all body language and
dialogue that gives him
emotion.
But in comics you
can play around
with physics a little more.
[LAUGHTER]
You can kind of change
his helmet a little bit.
So if you look at
the book, there
are times when I'll
change things subtly
in his helmet to give him a
little wider range of emotion.
One thing I learned when
I was doing the first book
was that you can't
make Vader too dark.
And in fact, the
first book you'll see
is like a little inconsistent
about how dark Vader ends up
being.
So you can't color him in
too black and that's easy.
So that's how you draw Vader.
And so now I guess I'll
answer-- well, we'll talk
and then we'll take
some questions?
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Yeah.
JEFFREY BROWN: Or I don't know
how long that just took me.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: I
think you're good.
Not a problem.
I think my first question
reads, how many times
have you seen "Star Wars?"
JEFFREY BROWN: You know I
was looking at my computer,
and it said I'd only watched
"Empire Strikes Back"
six times, and I hadn't
watched the other ones at all.
So I think iTunes might
be wrong about that.
But probably like
hundreds of times,
at least for the first original
trilogy, and the prequels
maybe 20 times [INAUDIBLE].
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Do
you find yourself
watching it every time
you're writing a new book?
I assume you know
much of it by memory.
JEFFREY BROWN: Yeah.
Definitely the first few books,
and then the last book just
a little less.
But then I'll go back when
I'm working with drawings
I'll use a combination of
watching the films and pausing,
and then also lots of
reference books and things.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: I think the
question I'm probably obligated
to ask is so this idea actually
came from a scratch Google
Doodle idea.
JEFFREY BROWN: It did.
It started here.
So I had met Ryan Germich who
runs the Google Doodle team.
And they had come
up with an idea
about doing something with
Vader for Father's Day.
And their idea was how awkward
an everyday father-son moment
would have if Luke came
home for Thanksgiving
and they were having
Thanksgiving dinner
with Luke and Vader.
And I was a father
at that point,
and I had met
Ryan, in fact, when
I was started out doing
autobiographical comics, which
all my autobiographical
comics are all
about awkward everyday moments.
And I'd also done humorous
science fiction parity stuff.
So he thought I'd
be a good person
to bring in and see if
I could do something.
So my son was four at the time,
so I basically turned Luke
into a four-year-old.
I thought that would be perfect.
And then put Vader in
my shoes as a parent.
And then, yeah, they ended
up using a different concept.
And I was really
bummed at first,
and then I realized
I could take the idea
and I could do more with
it, and I could actually
turn it into a book.
So it actually worked out--
DANA HAN-KLEIN: It worked
out better for you.
JEFFREY BROWN: really,
really well for me.
We might have missed
out on that one.
Yeah, so you've mentioned
your previous works are really
emotional, kind of you
as being a young adult
or being in the early
stage of adulthood.
And now you're exploring
being a father.
And what's the
next step for you?
JEFFREY BROWN: Dying.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: OK.
All right.
[LAUGHTER]
JEFFREY BROWN: No.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: That's
the end of a trilogy.
JEFFREY BROWN: You're young
and then you fall in love
and then you have
kids and then you die.
Yeah, I think as far
as autobiographical,
the Vader books are
autobiographical in a way
because it's about parenting
and being a parent.
I draw on my own experiences.
And I did another
"Star Wars" series
called "Jedi Academy," which is
middle school set in the "Star
Wars" universe.
And there's lots
of things in there
that are straight out of my own
experiences from middle school.
So autobiographical, I feel like
I've covered everything that's
happened in my life up to now.
So you need to wait
till I do more stuff.
So right now I'm
actually working
on a book about Neanderthals.
I'm just trying to go as
far opposite from science
fiction, "Star Wars" as I can.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Far
in the [INAUDIBLE].
JEFFREY BROWN: So I
wanted to do something
about cavemen that was based
on actual research more
than the traditional
media portrayals for kids
where it's "Flintstones"
where they're driving--
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Dinosaurs.
They're pulling cars.
JEFFREY BROWN: --dinosaur cars.
Or "Captain Caveman."
I don't know if anyone
remembers "Captain Caveman,"
but he's this hairy guy and
he'll pull telephones out
of his hair.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Look forward
to the revival of that.
So who are some of
your influences then?
JEFFREY BROWN: Jeez,
where to start.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Well, I
assume the writing part
and the illustration part
have different influences.
JEFFREY BROWN: Well,
they do and they don't.
I mean there's lots
of cartoonists.
So there's some
autobiographical cartoonists
who were big influences.
Julie Doucet is a Canadian
artist who doesn't really
do comics as much anymore.
But her work was
really influential.
Chris Ware and Dan
Clowes are guys
that were big influences on me.
But I feel like as an artist
you try and draw influences
from many.
So music is a big
influence for me.
So just the idea of
song writing and writing
a song that can have some
kind of emotional impact.
So when I hear a song
that does that for me,
then it makes me want
to draw comics that
can do that for someone else.
And "Star Wars,"
I mean "Star Wars"
was a big influence growing up.
So I grew up with the
movies and the trading cards
and everything, but there's a
book called "The Empire Strikes
Back Notebook," which had a
lot of the production art.
And seeing that was something
that I found really inspiring
as a kid, and realizing there's
people doing all these drawings
before the movie gets made, and
that seemed like a lot of fun
to me.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: In
what order will you
let your children watch
the "Star Wars" movie?
Will you let them watch all
six or nine by the time that
we're--
JEFFREY BROWN: So my
older son is eight,
and so far he's
watched "Star Wars"
and "Empire Strikes Back," or
"A New Hope" and "Empire Strikes
Back" in that order.
And our younger
son is two and he
started to watch--
he watched "New Hope"
and then he started to
watch "Empire Strikes Back."
Because I figured
the second kid,
you just let them do whatever.
So I figured he was old enough.
He didn't need to
wait any longer.
I saw "Star Wars"
when I was two,
and I'm the youngest of three.
So it made sense.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Yeah.
It paid off for you.
JEFFREY BROWN: So do
that, then the prequels.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Now everything
is supposed to be canon, right?
So does that mean that
four-year-old Luke is actually
part of the "Star
Wars" canon officially?
JEFFREY BROWN: No, I think
that still operates--
DANA HAN-KLEIN: You
guys have go to pass on.
JEFFREY BROWN: Yeah.
I think it's a weird thing.
It's not parity, it's
not satire exactly.
And that was one of the reasons
why I want it to be officially
Lucas Film license
was I didn't want
to have to make it
dark father lord
and then make up
dialogue and everything,
and just have it seem like a
slightly funny cheap knockoff.
And so yeah, I don't
know where it fits in.
Personally, I think that
maybe, especially comic book
companies, but also in cases
like "Star Wars," people
worry too much about
continuity and canon.
For me, George Lucas,
his rule was always
that if the films are
canon then everything else
is something else.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Extended, yeah.
JEFFREY BROWN: And
I like the idea
of being able to do different
things with the characters.
It's great to be able to
make your own characters
and stories, and
there's a certain kind
of creative process
that that brings.
But when you have
characters that
have such a weighted
history, you
can do different
things a lot easier
and you can use that
history with them
in ways that would take
too much time to build up
with your own material.
But yeah, I don't really
worry where they'll fit in.
I mean I figure as long as
I'm having fun drawing them,
that's my concern.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: What are
some of your favorite moments
from the movies that
got incorporated
in kind of your own spin, way.
Because when I read
the books and I hear
Darth Vader's voice in
my head saying the line,
but it's in a totally
different situation.
JEFFREY BROWN: I think
one of my favorites
is in "Vader's Little Princess,"
there's the scene where
Leia and Hansel are kissing
and then you have Vader going,
"No!"
[LAUGHTER]
And I thought it
was a really fun way
to poke fun at the whole "no"
controversy, but also just
a really funny joke on its own.
I did have an alternate version
of Leia and Luke kissing,
and Vader, "No!"
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Maybe
a little too dark.
JEFFREY BROWN: Yeah,
it seemed like that
was going too far maybe.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: The explanation
required for that one.
I also loved when
Darth Vader leads
Han to the carbonite
chamber after,
being a seventh grade
interpretation on that.
JEFFREY BROWN: Yeah, I
wondered how much of that
was subconscious.
He's like, "That guy."
I'm just picking him
at random, but yeah.
DANA HAN KLEIN: There's
something about him
I don't like.
What color light
saber would you have?
JEFFREY BROWN: Blue.
DANA HAN-KLEIN:
Wookies or ewoks?
JEFFREY BROWN: Ewoks.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: What
piece of "Star Wars"
memorabilia would
you love to have?
JEFFREY BROWN:
Oh, I mean I would
love to have one of
the storyboard drawings
by Joe Johnston or any
of that production art
would be really cool
to have I think.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: If you were
hosting a dinner party,
you can have three characters
from "Star Wars" universe
there.
Who do you want?
It's just rapid
fire nerd question.
JEFFREY BROWN: So Yoda,
because he's my favorite.
He's funny.
R2-D2 because then he
could bring drinks.
[LAUGHTER]
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Good answer.
JEFFREY BROWN: I
don't know, a tauntaun
to provide drive home randomly.
Does that count as a character
or is that like a creature?
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Yeah.
It could be a character.
So you've mentioned you're
going to work on Neanderthals.
Are there any other
franchises you might explore?
You mentioned "Lord
of the Rings" a lot
in your other work.
JEFFREY BROWN: Yeah.
I grew up reading a
lot of fantasy also,
and was a big Tolkien fan.
That would be a lot of
fun to do at some point.
I'm not as big a
"Star Trek" fan,
but especially the
original series
and the Captain Kirk movies I
think have a lot of potential.
That would be fun to do
something with those.
And lately, I like watching
"Game of Thrones" a lot.
And I was like oh, "Game
of Thrones." what could you
do with "Game of Thrones?"
DANA HAN-KLEIN: A lot.
JEFFREY BROWN: There's no
end to the possibilities.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Cool.
So what are you
reading right now?
JEFFREY BROWN: What am
I reading right now?
What did I just read?
I don't know.
Well, I'll talk about what I'm
looking forward to reading.
Haruki Murakami has
his first two novellas
are coming out in English
for the first time.
Well, in America.
And I had actually read them
because a friend had copies
that he got in Japan
that were in English.
So I'm looking forward
to reading that when
it comes out because I
haven't read it since.
So honestly, right now I'm
reading this "You Might Be A
Zombie Book" that's a collection
of craked.com humor stuff.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: [LAUGH]
JEFFREY BROWN: Sorry,
it's really [INAUDIBLE].
DANA HAN-KLEIN: That's
not a bad answer.
JEFFREY BROWN: It's honesty.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Yeah.
That's what we want here.
What are some of the best books
that you've discovered having
your own kids, and have
those ever influenced--
I mean obviously, "Goodnight
Darth Vader" is kind of a--
JEFFREY BROWN: I
mean I don't know
if it's so much as I've
discover-- I mean I
guess I have discovered a lot.
But a lot of it's
re-discovering books.
So my mom saves everything,
so she had all my books
from when I was a kid in a box.
And so they've just
been incorporated
into my kids' libraries.
And so "Goodnight
Moon" is a classic.
And then just reading other
Margaret Wise Brown books
that I haven't read when
I was a kid, or at least I
don't remember reading.
There's a book called
"Bagel's Lucky Hat"
that's out-of-print
unfortunately,
but it's actually
a kids book that
was written under a
pseudonym by a guy Dave
Cooper who's a cartoonist who's
another influence of mine.
And then yeah, one of the
big books for me growing up
was a book called "Small in the
Saddle" by Mark Alan Stamaty.
And after having our first
son, and I went and got
all these other kids books.
So the one that's
widely available
now is "Who Needs
Donuts?" which is also
a lot of fun, a lot of crazy
really intricate drawings.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: If you could
go back in time 15 years, what
would you tell yourself.
JEFFREY BROWN: 15 years.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: 10
years, 15 years.
JEFFREY BROWN: What was I doing?
I wouldn't tell myself anything.
I probably couldn't
even look at myself.
[LAUGHTER]
DANA HAN-KLEIN: OK.
JEFFREY BROWN: I mean I turned
out relatively OK, but--
DANA HAN-KLEIN: There's
no looking backwards.
JEFFREY BROWN: Yeah,
those early 20s, ugh.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: You've kind
of documented a lot of your--
JEFFREY BROWN: Yeah.
If you read them you'll see.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: I have.
I've read them.
JEFFREY BROWN:
I've relived that.
There's nothing I
can tell myself.
I was beyond help.
[LAUGHTER]
Just needed to go through it.
Get the crying over with.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: OK, so my
last question before we
turn to audience
questions, and you
don't have to, but what is
your either best Darth Vader
or wookie impression?
JEFFREY BROWN: Oh.
I do wookie impressions
for my kids.
But it's not something
I would pull out here.
[LAUGHTER]
[DARTH VADER VOICE]
All too easy.
It's better with a microphone.
[BREATHING]
DANA HAN-KLEIN: There we go.
Cool.
So we have time for
some audience questions.
If anyone has any,
now's your chance.
AUDIENCE: So who
gets final cuts when
some of the stuff
that you're doing
pushes on Lucas's idea
of I guess a brand?
JEFFREY BROWN: Lucas Films.
They have the final cut.
But strangely, it's been
super smooth process.
And part of it is I kind of
know what they would cut anyway,
and so I don't push it too much.
But also I think the nature of
the books, especially the Vader
books where they are kind
of sweet and wanting them
to kind of be something
that is good for both
the parents and the kids.
I don't know.
It's just always ended up in a
space where there's never been
anything where they're like no.
At least nothing that I was
like no, it has to be like this.
So there's things I push back
on that they were like, OK.
But I don't think-- I mean like
some of the sketches in there,
and I had others
for the other books,
like jokes about Luke's hand
getting cut off and things.
I kind of knew that those
weren't going to make it,
but I was also OK with that.
AUDIENCE: Do you notice
any kind of difference
from pre and post [INAUDIBLE]?
JEFFREY BROWN: I if there's
more of a difference
for the publishers and
working out their licensing
deals than there's been for me.
I mean I'm working with
the same people in general
that I was working with before.
The biggest thing was right when
the acquisition happened they
kind of put everything on hold.
So I'd actually pitched the
"Goodnight Darth Vader book
and what became "Darth Vader and
Friends" right around the time
the acquisition
happened, and they
were like we need to
just wait and see.
And same with, at that point,
"Jedi Academy One" was out.
And we thought it
could become a trilogy,
and they were like we don't
know if we can do more just yet.
And so that was the
only difference for me
at that point.
But creatively, it's really
been the same process.
Maybe some of the feedback
takes a little bit longer
to hear back from them,
but not a huge amount.
DANA HAN-KLEIN: Well, thank
you so much for joining us.
It was fun to have you here.
Give him a round of applause.